I'm really sorry guys we really screwed
up a lot of you may have noticed in some
of the videos recently how crappy the
audio quality is that's because my
camera guy messed up on the audio I've
been using him camera guy for a long
time and he's great and he really cares
deeply about the quality of the videos
it takes a lot of pride in his work and
we didn't notice that they have so I
film once a month from the China that
tells the studio's usually the first or
second Thursday no first a second
Wednesday of the month and we just
recorded and he didn't notice that the
audio wasn't picking up properly and we
just basically figured that once we
transferred all the files and I know a
lot of you guys are complaining a lot of
you guys are upset and rightfully so the
audio sounds like junk and it's not our
usual standard and I appreciate the love
I appreciate the support I appreciate
you trying to hold me to higher
standards I I sincerely do so we had
options you know is either we keep it up
as it is I'm not filming it again for
our schedule until the beginning of next
month and we just said you know what the
points are still good the points are
still good
I like the content the audio sucks but
the point is still good I still want to
give you guys value it's not what you're
used to and again I'm sorry but the
content is still good and I hope you
will bear with me have some patience as
these videos keep coming out until
probably the first week of August maybe
the second come out is just depend on
production schedule yeah and you know
what mess ups happen we try to avoid
them we try to eliminate them I'm sure
you guys messed up a couple times in
your business and you go through you
battle on you fix them for the next time
and hope that they hope they don't
happen again and I'd love to hear what
messed up you had recently in your
business leave that down in the comments
below make me feel good for our team
messing up and disappointing you guys I
think most of all just a disappointment
you know we try to make content that is
high quality that I'm really proud of
there's a lot of work that my entire
team puts into creating the videos that
we make every week for you guys to help
you stay motivated and get ideas and
it's really a lot of love everybody I
promise you everybody on the team puts a
ton of love into making sure that it's a
good quality product as best as we know
how to make and sometimes we mess up and
this was a pretty big mess up and I'm
really I'm really sorry to do that to
you guys I'm way harder on myself trust
me in the comments that you guys have
for me coming in and thank you too for
the support there's been some really
supportive comments so thank you for the
love I really appreciate it and again
hopefully you can bear with us until we
get to the next group of recording but
in the meantime continue to enjoy use it
as an opportunity to remember the good
quality content and be grateful for what
is coming ahead awesome stuff next time
I promise thank you guys again to the
support and I'm sorry
hope you have a great weekend you need
to believe in whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon